the european union's three main
institutions have clinched a deal on the
eu's budget for the next seven years
once endorsed by member states and the
european parliament it will provide some
960 billion euros for the 2014 to 2020
period with the focus on promoting
economic growth and jobs
this is a an important day for 500
million citizens it's also an important
day for the 26 million people who are
unemployed in this union and what we now
have to do in ratifying this political
agreement
by the institutions is to see that these
monies are channeled into effective
programs so that people all over this
union have the opportunity to have jobs
and careers as a consequence
a big slice of the package could be
front loaded onto the budget in the
first two years to tackle rampant youth
unemployment
the money could be injected into
apprenticeship schemes and small
businesses as well as research and the
erasmus lifelong learning program
the budget known as the multi-annual
financial framework is used to bring
europe's poorest regions into line with
their partners finance agricultural
spending infrastructure and education as
well as provide assistance to non-eu
nations
the institutions have pledged to
officially endorse the package by july
9.